what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to Chris Brown's side of
the story as you guys may or may not
know
um a couple years ago it was literally
huge news that Chris Brown had beat up
Rihanna but apparently there's two sides
to the story that I did not actually
know about but before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it guys make sure
you subscribe to the Channel I want to
get a million Subs before New Year's Eve
that's a very lofty goal for the channel
it would actually be like groundbreaking
kind of separable you know you hear
about them being in the studio you would
hear you know they're coming into the
club together and it was just it was
just an energy at that time in our
career being that young
gullible how old were the people always
say young but they're never that yet can
you look up how young they were also
just happy just just wanting to be
everywhere I mean it was no other
feeling like it but with her with Marie
it was just like
or that we had at that age it was just
it's dangerous man okay that actually is
pretty I'll give you that I'll give you
that you can go anywhere like we
couldn't go to a hotel and I have a
thousand fans outside
we couldn't go to any restaurant and
just eat like real life rock stars had
16 and 17 years old man that's dangerous
because you could do whatever you want I
just think we were like the perfect
like and bad combination like it was
just good and bad together it was just I
want to say maybe a year and a half into
the relationship
I just I really
was serious about it like you know I was
I was always goofy about everything else
being a young kid but
maturity level I had
in my belief with what I wanted my
girlfriend you know what I want to marry
you but I want before you know we go any
further I just want to be able to be
honest with me completely real with you
about everything you've ever had a
question about or doubt about or she had
asked me like right he was cheating one
thing I mean he was a 19 year old rock
star he had hoes let's just be real here
first started dating hey you ever mess
with this this person and this person uh
she worked for me at the time and I said
no no no man you know
you know you know I brush it to the side
one I didn't want hurting all my
business too I just didn't know who she
would tell if I was telling what I'm
doing you know what I'm saying so
I went like the eighth month so maybe
like a little bit after that VMA
performance
it's broken to us hey I want to marry
you but I want to be real with you I
want to be honest with you until you you
know everything
it is before we were together me and
this other girl did have sex
my trust totally was the loss with her
you know what I'm saying she hated me
after that I tried everything like
like she didn't get it like she just
didn't trust me from there
went down here because you know so
before they were together they were
probably together
[Laughter]
I'll take your word Chris
but I mean he was a rock I don't blame
him like he was fighting to be verbal
fights physical fights as well Mutual
size and this is the first time I get to
say anything and like I said I still
love Rihanna but it's it's
uh the woman is me in me is like oh he
still loves her
ah Let each other she would hit me away
at her
um and but
it was always it was always a point to
where we we talk about him like yo what
the [ __ ] are you doing wait did he just
say I think I was laughing did did he
say I hit her look I'm big equal rights
equal laughs baby you hit expect to get
hit back it's not abuse you're just both
toxic like I don't like that I'm like
you slapping me if I go on stage I got a
scratch on my face and I gotta explain
it like oh and I feel like oh you or
like if you gotta if you got a scar or
whatever bruise you gotta put makeup on
it I feel like [ __ ] like I'm like I'm
not like I'm not ever trying to put my
hands on any female
like me I felt like a [ __ ] monster
seven years ago when I was about 17 18.
you know the whole Rihanna incident
happened you know a lot of that that
changed my life
okay this is from my point of view a
couple years ago now remember this is
pre-red pill so
I remember Chris Brown beat up Rihanna
and it was really big news and I think
he I don't know if he went to jail or
got charged or exactly what happened but
I just remember like Rihanna was this
huge victim everyone felt so bad for her
and she had
um that song what was it called
[Music]
love on the brain and there's a lyric in
there
it's so bad it's like he beats me black
and blue but he [ __ ] me so good and I
can't get enough and I'm like that was
about Chris Brown that was about Chris
Brown so it was clearly there's a reason
she stayed you know I mean
and then later that cloud Davis party
that I made sure
the person that I was involved with
before I said hey if you can't come
around to these places
and the person comes in
I'm so curious who do you know who the
person is anyone no no who I wonder who
it was comes right to the table say hey
what's up y'all
I already know it's an issue so I say
hey cool and I keep it and they they
keep it moving they leave I look I look
over at Rihanna and she's bawling she's
just crying in the middle of the
ceremony about to start she's just
crying and I'm like yo yo yo yo please
please baby don't do this like don't do
this in here like like I didn't know I
promise I swear to God I didn't know so
she got over it she started drinking the
Red Pill on me it's like his side chick
came up I just the way the story the
story would make a lot more sense if he
admitted she was a side chick for a
while and that makes it like honestly
what do you expect dating a national
Superstar like you could have dated the
average Joe he would not cheat on you
well he might but
but it's less likely like you picked a
19 year old Superstar I I think we've
just lived in a gynocentric social order
for so long like we tell women you can
have everything you can have the good
looking guy the Superstar and he's still
gonna not cheat on you no unfortunately
now I you know I wish I could sell you
that dream but it's just it is what it
is I can't tell the world how to be
a little bit it was Tipsy laughing
joking you know and then we left
and Juan just a few hours ago we saw
Chris Brown Drive off according to
sources the alleged fight broke out
inside a Lamborghini that was located at
Hancock Park as you know young
relationships you need relationship is
based on trust but because I told her
that she didn't trust me with anything
so I would I would give her the option
oh you can look at my phone so I gave
her the phone
you think there's nothing on the phone
which you guys a 19 year old Superstar
all of your celebrity crushes I I think
I think man would fail good I think
great men would still I think that would
be hard for any man to turn down
honestly Genesis
kill the Grammys
do your thing
and I didn't read the rest of the
message
so she opened the message and the rest
of the message say I'll see you at the
cloud party
so I was thought you thought I was lying
she starts going off she throws the
phone I hate you whatever whatever
starts hitting me win a little
Lamborghini you know she's fighting me
and I'm like look I'm telling you the
truth I swear to God you know I'm
telling you the truth stop it so then
she hits me a couple more times and I
and I just kind of just it doesn't go
from translation to let's sit down I'm
telling you the truth it goes to now I'm
feeling be mean and be evil are you an
argue and argue you didn't like like I
remember she tried to kick me it's like
just her just being upset
but then I really hit him like I like it
was a closed fish like I punched him you
know and it uh busted her lip and when I
saw it I was in shock I was like yeah
and that's the thing like a lot of girls
don't talk about how they start hitting
him first equal rights equal lefts bait
like what did you think was gonna happen
you're hitting a grown man you're
hitting a grown man it's not like he's a
old guy it's like an a 19 year old guy I
don't know I just think
I just think don't hit a guy if you
don't want to get hit back why the hell
did I hit her like so from there she's
just been in my face like it's been the
blood on my face and I'm like you know
so it raised me even more like it's a
really long fight in the car we driving
in the street so I'm like yo
hey y'all we tripping what the [ __ ] like
what are we doing she's trying to grab
from my phone I'm not getting giving her
my phone to throw it out of the window
so she grabs my nuts
as I'm driving because I'm still trying
to drive he's gonna crash the car what
is he supposed to he's gonna crack like
you want him to crash the car and then
both of you are dead it's like a petty
like stupid fight bro like and I'm just
realizing and I'm like what the hell am
I doing bro what do you like you
honestly doing this in a car right now
like what are we doing so I pull over in
Hancock Park we need maybe less than two
three miles from my house because I'm
just trying to resolve the situation I'm
not trying to fight any further I don't
want to like I love that I don't want to
hurt my girlfriend
you know so
I pull over
and I said look like I'm telling you the
truth like I'm crying she's crying like
I'm telling you the truth I swear to God
like I didn't do it I didn't like I
didn't know she was [ __ ] coming I
didn't know I promise she just didn't
believe me like she said I just know you
lying to me you lying to me
takes the keys out of the car I'm
important she takes the keys out of her
car and throws face like she throws them
out the window
and I'm like what are you doing and I
get out the car when I get out the car
I'm looking for the keys and somebody
yard
and she uh she yells out on her do help
he's trying to kill me I said stop like
we're gonna get in trouble
so I'm looking for the keys she's
sitting on the keys
so I'm like you know what I can't play
this game with you so she I'm getting my
bags out of the car she takes my CDs
this is back when I will record on CDs
you couldn't put it on your phone in the
studio so I had new music and she was
just scratching it up I just seen her
scratching her with the keys I thought
I'd snatched the bag
and I was like you know what you got the
keys you drive home by this time when it
was busting she had a night because I
pushed her head up against the window
you know a lot a lot of the times like I
look back at that picture and I'm just
like oh man he clocked her oh wow I mean
look equal rights equal last bit I stand
on it that's just oh he hit her hard
yo bro right but equal rights equal
lefts baby you hit expect to get hit
back I stand on that I stand on that
it's not me bro that's not that's not me
and she ruined his career for a couple
years I mean he came back he's Chris
Brown he's coming back
I just I hate it to this day you know
what I'm saying that's gonna haunt me
forever I hated myself you know so I
didn't I was thinking about suicide and
everything else so it's just like [ __ ]
but
my consequences for my actions have to
be dealt with you know I turn myself in
the next day
clear guilty didn't didn't you know
argue didn't say hey now let's let me
fight this case and take it to trial and
just say hey she fought me back up I'm
not that's that's not where my head was
at and that's not where these he is now
and here's the thing this is what
happens like if that happened to a man
with money power and fame how many
minutes that happened to you that's the
thing like the truth always comes out
sooner or later like the truth comes out
and you can't hide it forever and yeah
this is this is really sad because he
really like he was so brainwashed he
thought that he was completely in the
wrong even though she hit first she hit
first I'm curious if like what because I
feel like I heard something that she was
somewhat defending him at the time but I
don't actually know I don't I don't want
to say that I I loved her you know I I
wanted to protect her because I did too
much stuff to her like I did what I did
so it was wrong the hardest you know
person to say
like I'll talk about it too what would
be
[Music]
I would say probably my father you know
what I'm saying my father and my real
father
I don't want to disappoint my father
because he actually was different
for my mom it was a little bit more
closer to heart because I seen my mom
deal with that you know firsthand not
from my father my biological father
Clinton Maurice Brown is a great man
you know but her
significant other at the time my mother
you know he was a monster animal pure
hatred evil I never hated somebody in my
life like
if I like if I could kill him so I
promised my mom one day
I said look ma you know if I like I know
you tell me not to do like crazy [ __ ]
and hang with these [ __ ] and do what I
do I said but when I get 15 I'm gonna
kill him
like I'm not playing I'm not I'm not
joking I'm serious I'm gonna take his
life so that's the kind of hatred this
guy brings for me and fear and stuff
like that so I'm terrified of this man
you know I would be at home you know
blew his brains out when I was six but
he didn't die like he shot himself in
the head and then went blind and [ __ ] I
was six years old bro like the [ __ ] how
does the kid deal with that [ __ ]
and then
being that he's physically impaired now
it frustrates him more so he's in the
depression
so but he takes it out on his group this
girl happens to be my mom
this is what I had to deal with like I
had to hear my mom get beat up every
night and I had to pee on myself like
I'm scared scared to even get up walking
the hallway because I ain't want to see
nothing you know what I'm saying so
nobody knows that fear that they have to
deal with and then
it transcends sometimes it's learned
behavior
so me having to see my mom look at me
through that light
like
I just saw him that's who that's who I
saw I saw him I didn't see Chris I seen
that [ __ ] oh that's really sad
it's really sad
and so that's what it means a lot that's
what killed my soul a lot when did this
come out do you know a couple years ago
he was saying he still loves Rihanna and
this was like over 10 years wow that was
I was the the one thing I was running
from
the label the name woman beater
is something I would say to somebody you
know what I'm saying oh that's so sad
because that I would place that judgment
not equal rights equal laughs if you had
expect to get hit
so when people say it I don't get mad at
them I'm more mad at myself because I
feel like I am the reflection of what
they're saying that was really
interesting to hear his side of the
story I when I heard that he was telling
his side of the story I had a feeling
that it might go something something
like this just because of all the other
stuff we've seen in the media with like
Johnny Depp Amber Heard and like other
similar cases
um but yeah that's really sad that he
basically I I was so young so I don't
remember it that clearly but I really
remember him having a really bad
reputation for a couple years and I
remember people really looking at him
like he was a monster and it's sad
because I mean he really didn't do
anything wrong if you hit if she started
it he finished it really and she kept
provoking him even after like he was he
was trying to say stop so I don't know I
think this is a really important lesson
to the young women out there guys if you
hit someone expect to get hit back don't
don't be hitting grown ass man that can
beat you up because one of these days
you will get hit and it's going to hurt
and we're in a more present time where
he might not have to plead guilty for
that anymore hopefully so anyways let me
know what you guys think in the comments
subscribe to the channel like the video
on your way out especially subscribe we
are trying to hit a million before New
Year's and I will talk to you next time
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible